all right welcome back to the truth
geordie podcast it is the most
talked-about documentary in the world
right now one of the biggest
documentaries of all time we are lucky
enough to be joined by one of the stars
one of the main characters it's bhagavad
and also known as doc hi doc how you
doing man I'm fantastic me thanks for
joining us I can't quite believe this
you guys have turned into it's almost
like you're not real
even though you're real people it feels
because of the way they did the
documentary you guys feel like scripted
actors you know how do you how's it be
in the last couple of weeks you know
it's a salacious outrageous ride Tiger
King is you know not a documentary and
but it is this incredible crazy time it
is exposed as to a much broader market
in some ways we'll get to probably just
ridiculously famous for things that
aren't true but you know in other ways
it just exposes people to the bigger
picture I think it lets me know more
about big cats because Tigers are in
desperate need of help the worldwide and
we hope that this brings attention to
their plight which is the only thing
important that came out of it so I
noticed that coral busken's husband did
a little video where he said that they'd
give him this speech before you agree to
be in the documentary about how they
were gonna make the black fish of Tigers
did you get the same speech well I got a
speech similar I was told hey we're
gonna make this show they're going after
your heartstrings so I was told hey
we're gonna make a show about your
international conservation work because
I have great projects around the world I
have a ranger station I operate in the
deep jungles of Sumatra I've got my
fingers there we travel there we've some
puns the puns into it we're going to
document how Tigers in America are
saving Tigers in the wild is that's what
I live for
hey port added my ear telling me oh
you're gonna have this what what because
you're your conservation program he told
her that you know she's gonna do that
stuff about the blackfish which is
absurd because it doesn't equate to the
same thing and I'm sure her husband got
out there and said whatever he was
supposed to because she's gonna pour
sardine oil on him and feed
oh I love it
Oh will ok we'll definitely get onto
that definitely but you know in the
first episode take me but almost as
you're watching I'm assuming you watch
it on Netflix when we did they opened up
and they say these guys are backstabbers
these guys are bad people they don't
even give you a time as an audience
member to make your own mind on what was
it like being a part of that watching
what they were saying about you
instantly before you'd even been shown I
mean it just looks like outrageous
slander right that they're just trying
to paint a picture of some crazy
salacious sensational idea to lock
people in that something outrageous is
happening something outrageous did
happen what I described in there is a
wild rug using homosexual dude that just
is on fire his personal choices but he's
outrageous to a fault and Carols is
creepy and as weird as a person gets
just seems like a serial killer
that's wild stop being so they could
take the ritz-carlton of big cat
facility and Brian tie it in somehow
they were grasping at any straw they
could get to create drama when the
producers were here hanging out they
were filming and talking to me
Rebecca said so many weird things to me
while we were making this conservation
program about lifestyle and girls and
stuff going on I thought she was hitting
on me or something she asked me such
weird stuff and I said dude to Eric I
said that chick can't come back again I
threw her out I said I don't want to see
her again something was wrong here but I
was too fanatic on running my
conservation program and getting this
message out allowed them to come back
for years without her and Jaime into
this insanity that became the crazy ride
of agregate tell me just going back to
the Tigers what is it like to look in
the eyes of a tiger I've never done that
before what does it feel like when you
do though
something I wish everyone had the chance
to do because I think it would give you
a deeper connection and a more profound
experience of nature in its most raw
form a tiger has such a presence one it
has what I call God's greatest paint job
that outrageous striped face which is
just hard to believe it's meant to look
that way and then it is just a purveyor
of death this is a guy that is eight
feet tall weighs 600 pounds
as a 10 inch arm span and he's got ten
knives he's way past Wolverine and
that's who deal in love and kindness or
death at the twitch of an eye and he's
super cool but also incredibly intense
most of the time
Tigers are caring they get along very
well with me they have this really neat
social dynamic mothers raise their kids
if you can get along with them well this
way if they bond with you and they make
this explain that Tiger looks at you
very lovingly Tigers do what's called
the long blink and there it when they
find something infatuating or they find
that they want to show emotion they
stare into your eyes and they open and
close their eyes very slowly and that's
the long blade see them doing that to
you and being around it is a rush like
no other it's connection to nature
that's just unbelievable
at one point we've seen you entering on
an elephant and that made me question of
all of these animals that you have which
one of them would you be like I don't
want to be on my own with that one too
long is there any of them which you're
like most a bit scared of no I'm not
scared I grew up a professional cowboy
with 500 horses and 10,000 cows I worked
in rodeo I worked out there in the wilds
sleeping eating and breathing with my
horses and my I'm six gun on my hip real
pro chemically in the 1960s my dad is
John Wayne everything John Wayne did in
a movie my dad did in real life us plus
he was a scream character though I just
have a lifestyle for me an opportunity I
Mette Tigers but I don't want to
interact with and those Tigers I don't
interact it but I've met more than a
hundred that are incredibly charming and
are just waiting for the opportunity to
go for a walk to go for a swim they love
adventure they'll come right out right
to your hip and are incredible guys
who look at my Instagram today as a
great picture of my son with a huge
tiger you're walking along my son
replaced me as the living Tarzan guy
here because he got big and I got old
and fat and he's out there cruising
around with that those huge Tigers that
he's diving in a pool letting them swim
with him that lifestyle is something
that you can have if you learn the
language of Tiger it's like walking what
I say here in the States I'm sure its
equivalent there may be the same thing
in England you walk into a bar full of
Hells Angels it's a dangerous situation
if you say the wrong thing and do the
wrong stuff you might cross a line
intentionally or unintentionally that
could get you killed that is what it's
like to be around Tigers if you're one
of the Angels and you come in you're
greeted with sure love and understanding
and common Rodri that's how it is for me
to be with the tiger I'm part of the
team tiger and they always are waiting
for me to come around and have next
interaction that's really well explained
and I appreciate that there was one
moment in the show we obviously seen the
girl losing her arm which was awful she
clearly wasn't speaking the right
language that day but have you ever seen
in a moment or felt the moment yourself
where you thought I am in the most
trouble is there one moment that stands
out for you or as it has it because I
can't believe it's been plain sailing
this entire time surely you know again I
guess it's probably like riding a
motorcycle you know I certainly love a
Harley I've been out on one going way
over a hundred miles an hour and it's an
incredible thrill I've had fools full-on
into the road while I was being a fool
on the motorcycle going too fast and
gone
oh no okay okay that happens with Tigers
sometimes they reach out and they say
that's mine and cheating
outcome blades is bigging your fingers
and they reach out and say snatch and it
goes right asked you because if they
catch another tiger across the face it
stings if it's a person across the face
it comes up off right so I have felt the
breeze before and that has been
outrageous I've had it knit me tear my
shirt off and barely harm my skin from
that right timing you got to learn to
dodge and move at the right time my son
falls you got a Jew
I got a toque out the way he's master at
it and I've had my time with it you must
be like Floyd Mayweather by this time
yeah I know
and Floyd is magical I don't know that I
am quite as outrageous of reaction time
is Floyd but it's certainly been my goal
in life as I've done this for 40 years
almost now you know I had so many
incredible times with giant I I've seen
you've had a lot of celebrity speaking
of Floyd I've seen you have the
Undertaker there recently I'm is there
any names that people might recognize
who come round
well Beyonce's been around you know you
guys great pictures of her hugging my my
son that's a chimpanzee and he was young
you can see Beyonce hugging on to him he
met blue ivy and you know played around
there jay-z came and petted Tigers and
hung around I could drop names on you
for an hour nine months with Jim Carrey
making a Smasher oh I stayed months
Eddie Murphy making him into dr.
Doolittle though I stayed with Bill
Paxton making mightyjoyoung
having bill become that character that's
trying to get the vibe of how he's this
wildlife got he's emulating me told me
spayed up what I'm gonna try and be in
the show what is the most simpler reason
for Tigers being so depleted like why is
this happened the number one reason the
Tigers are depleting is the incredible
increasing population of humans and
their need to absorb resources that's
really what it is the world is slowly
taking the biomass that exists and makes
the planet breathe and beat it it's
operating
natural state we're converting the
biomass in human mass there's so many of
us much larger population England's got
one of the great examples of it right
now
y'all are trapped on on an island and
your population is expanding ever faster
I look at the teachings there that are
being given out by Sir David
Attenborough optimum population trust
about what is going to happen is you're
one of the test sites of a population
older expansion where will you fit when
there is a billion people on your island
you know in terms of these like us that
we've seen in the show there's a there's
a bit of a debate about whether or not
that's ethical whether or not that
should have happened what's your take on
this it's a real long expansive concept
if you go to laggard laggard calm you
could get all the science behind it
liars are a naturally-occurring animal
everyone wants to pretend that
hybridization is somehow not part of
nature because of some Adam and Eve in
the Garden of Eden notion that that's
originally how we all must have been
that everything was there
the dinosaurs were living side by side
with elephants or something it just
doesn't make that much sense but it
holds a special place in our mind
hybrids existed throughout the world
seventeen countries and lion and tiger
populations just one hundred years ago
that lived in overlapping territories at
that time if you look at the genome you
can clearly see that lions and tigers
have genetic material this flowed back
and forth between he sees after they had
a common ancestor everybody wants to
roll back and say no no that's before
they diverged so this is in modern time
modern tigers and lions care each
other's DNA modern snow leopards care
modern lion DNA that is as part of the
big history they are all very
interconnected every lion tiger leopard
and Jaguar can freely interbreed and
their offspring are not sterile they can
breed mo
generational and it's happened before
our giant laggers are incredibly
inspiring see the Undertaker with them
and this is a big dude hmm sky 6 foot 10
310 20 pounds of you know sping steel
and sex appeal it looks like a little
kid standing next that he just is
dwarfed that laggers 12 feet tall well
over 900 pounds and he's 6 feet tall
raised oh [__] he's on his hind legs
he's absolutely massive he's incredibly
healthy he's a little bit portly just
like I am he loves a good meal but he is
able to run 40 miles an hour in a couple
of steps and he's a magnificent guy you
dude live your science on YouTube live
your channel on YouTube you can see how
cool they are up close and in person
that was talk on the documentary well
whether or not was a documentary is
debatable but there was talk on there
about you moving animals on it was talk
about euthanasia and the user knows and
the animals is there a point where you
do not do the animals always stay at the
end of their life with you to you move
them on how do you know when and where
do you put them like how's this system
in place there are a very small amount
of Cubs that are born every year it's
greatly exaggerated big cat rescue arrow
basket who killed her husband says all
the time I have 200 comes a year to
anybody that will listen yeah this 500
females - do I have 80 big fat false
piece of snake and I have this tiny
group of Cubs that pop along three to
six Cubs are all that's needed to
interact with the public and they get to
interact and tell their 16 to 20 plus
weeks old I'm open seasonally so if I
have six Cubs I can do an entire season
12 would be a windfall those 12 Cubs
mostly all would stay with us their
entire life I also only interact with
the public
one two hours a week we're only open
three days a week
we don't have an endless passing around
of Cubs it's incredibly well regulated
it's super cool to do but it's not
free-for-all it's very structured the
pubs are incredibly important to us when
you're down to three thousand plus
animals you every single one is
essential to save this is a mistake
that's being made for the animal rights
people are dictating to zoos about not
allowing animals to reproduce well being
the inside I grow up we have a few we
have friends we are in the business for
40 years of being a Zoological Park we
have the zoos that we've met over the
years we have scissors that are
accredited by the American Zoo
Association supposedly the gold standard
of zoos by the Zoological Association of
America and the American Association of
zoos all competing clubs none of them
have any real merit or understanding of
the big picture of what's going on
they're much more worried about the game
more people go to zoos then all
professional sports events combined
there are billions of dollars a day
people forget the billions that is being
made in the suit industry mostly by the
giant zoos like Bronx to San Diego
places like that so as Tigers come along
the zoo's around the world ask me I have
a cub waiting list I never fulfill I can
always choose that are accredited ease
that we have a direct connection with or
have who are the accrediting body have
been able to have someone else have a
direct connection with and a few of them
you know very few Tigers every year
that's all that's necessary no Tigers
ever euthanize no Tigers ever put to
sleep absolutely unethical immoral and
unnecessary
they're super valuable you cannot find a
tiger in America if you google it right
now I want to buy a tiger tiger for sale
you'll find dozens of them for sale on
the Internet it's all a scam probably
find Cleopatra's earrings on there too
doesn't you're gonna get to be a bad cos
earrings it's baloney
no one's gonna deliver a tiger to you
they're either run out of Nigeria as a
scam thing that's going on no I got
fabulous Nigerian friends it's not a
boon to gets nice
they're smart and a figured out how to
run this get the money for extra stuff
or it's run by the animal rights people
themselves to spend by offshoots of PETA
Humane Society United States pretending
that there's a sale of these animals
they say in the beginning of the show
there's five to ten thousand Tigers in
America we know it's absolutely false
there's not a shred of information
anyone find any place to back that up
it's just the mantra of the animal
extremists there are twelve hundred
Tigers in America 50% of them are held
by crazy lunatics like Carroll Baskin
and the people that are running those
with this scam so Airy
there's nothing sanctuary about that
rotten backyard hobble of Ages that our
end together with wire he's got Tigers
crafting with rotting water bowls and
all this stuff
we all saw on the show you know it's
likely that Carol runs a organization
that is doing good for Tigers as it is
that she didn't put some sardine oil on
that husband and let him roll on to the
next step oh but what you say what do
you sorry you know everybody Tigers get
too old I'm out they never get too old
they're incredible at one day as they
are at 1,000 days that's an animal
rights propaganda some reason that
they're no longer useful is a tiny part
of its existence works very short time
fool it's not why they exist exist to
try and save the tiger hate this because
of unprecedentedly important genetic so
on the joy exotic alright he aspired to
be like you what was it like to just
hear that when you're watching this that
someone idolized you like that everybody
in the big cat world wishes they had a
facility like us we had the incredible
opportunity given to us where we made a
whole lot of money and have had a whole
lot of time and I have a vision for how
to do it right and tens of millions of
dollars later we were able to build this
Incred
we'll facility people wish to emulate
they want to do it on a dime they think
there's a cheaper way to do it they're
gonna gonna hire some flashier simpler
way to do it and it's just not true and
Joe wanted to build this but he didn't
have the opportunity and circumstances
to do it he didn't have the vision he
always talked to me saying what can I do
to improve my place how can we make your
quirt
I gave him advice as I do zoos around
the world contact me I am Susan Murphy I
am zoos in Mexico I have zoos across the
United States always asking me for
advice and how they can build a better
facility that will make the animals and
the people connected have a better time
Joe said those things to me go was
exposed to us he had a job in this town
of Myrtle Beach 20 million people a year
come to Myrtle Beach there's a lot of
tourists packed in here
Joe got a part-time gig doing a magic
show for another musician not himself
have a tiger their problems came up
where the tiger was living how it was
being cared for what was happening and I
intervened trying to make it better I
had to talk with Joe and some of his
guys there and try and so I got to know
him a little bit better there I don't
really have a real relationship with him
but that exchange of ideas that he was
hoping to implement didn't happen he got
obsessed Carol Joe became so obsessed
with Carolyn and it took over everything
else in his life started out with quite
a bit of money to quite a bit enough
high ideals he kind of fell off the deep
end chasing Carol I mean really fell off
he's been he got involved with snitch
jet low and James Garrett those rotten
characters came in and siphoned his life
off and then led him down the path of
entrapment and he could do this
murder-for-hire gig and I think they
dropped him into that which in the
United States is actually illegal you're
not supposed to go to jail for that I
don't know the whole ins and outs of it
I'm not saying Joe's innocent but I know
for sure
those guys are innocent my whole lot
wrong they made a deal but Joe in jail
we won't have to go to jail and that's
just not
now the system's both what did you think
about the other charges the euthanasia
of the Tigers like obviously you said
that doesn't happen
Joe admit it to do it himself were you
what were you reacting like as you were
watching him admit to that
Jose of the fool he didn't have the
right circumstances he did not
understand Joe is collecting Tigers from
all across the country big adults random
hilly Nellie going around just gathering
so much at 270 some Tigers there it's
impossible to properly care for them
he's feeding them out of the back of the
bad meat trunk at Walmart that's just
crazy land obviously his resources are
tapped at that point everything here is
restaurant quality food that you would
glad to eat yourself we would never a
percent agree with something like that
all of that creates health troubles he
had Tigers that were doing poorly in a
lot of trouble with all of that going
along and he made terrible choices by
deciding to pick and choose life and
death for animals but he really was
responsible for and needed to keep under
his care so it's a fool doing a fool's
errand you wish it happened and I wish
you would have asked me before he made
such a stupid decision but that kind of
stuff just rolls up he wasn't
euthanizing tiger cubs that's an animal
rights story that a tiger cub has a
timeout it grows to a certain point it's
too big it'll bite your fingers off
which is just absurd 50-pound Tigers not
even near as dangerous as a Rottweiler
it's it's not near the power of a big
dog but they want you to keep this
notion that tiger cubs have to have a
home there are no places in America
adopting tiger cubs because they've been
lost to photo ops that's all a big
propaganda machine that they're running
so it's also they're cuddly and they
want you to think that when they think
of what he did from the pictures I've
seen he's not my information students
this story there are big adult Tigers
that were killed they were euthanized
and Joe's idea he killed him how he
killed him and humane he killed them off
it's not it's zoos in America and
certainly in England certainly in the
Netherlands they they euthanized that
big giraffe do you remember that crazy
story
last year I think that's what it was
needed here before euthanizing animals
in the zoo does have something that goes
on we at the room in the space to not
have to do that at one box that they
keep Tigers in that exhibit is it
another one comes in they have nowhere
to put that tiger so they may euthanize
them it happens in America Joe is the
only person ever prosecuted for it if
you put euthanize tiger zoo in America
come up a hundred times none of them
were prosecuted no one even would
consider but go one go might have done
it more heinous Lee you might be more of
a scumbag in some capacity but he didn't
do anything to be prosecuted for to go
to prison like that morally it felt to
me sorry it felt to me buddy like the
the evidence they had was so weak on the
other charges
that they thought the only way we're
gonna get this done as if we slop as
much on him as possible and hope that
sends him
I believe you're absolutely correct
murder-for-hire was so weak they hired
the maintenance man it's jet Lowe's
full-time buddy and say hey by the way
this guy is a part-time hitman and he'll
give you a international traveling
hitman professional advice for $100,000
you would be dealing with a new friends
advice on how to kill your enemies the
whole thing is absurd and I think would
Joe fell into it Harrison we're
whispering in his ear just ridiculous
lies flying him with drugs and
opportunity in and blowing smoke up his
ass that there was gonna be some new
shiny world they were gonna offer him
but all they wanted to do was - out his
wealth kick him to the curb which is
where he was when they found him he'd
abandon the zoo
he's yeah he was tending bar they say in
the middle of nowhere Florida his life
of a shambles and previous to
meat-eating those characters everything
looked pretty rosy snow that his war
with Carroll was for him
entertaining some of us you know here
kitty kitties a hell of a story not song
that song so the that one of the sad
moments from Joe side was when he gave
on a ship moment it was mother and
basically it seemed to render her
bankrupt almost at the end a what what
did he make of that situation I think it
was a tragic situation I think his
mother was his greatest supporter he had
a great relationship going with his
parents and he was there with him
throughout the whole thing I think that
his relationship with Jeff Lowe helped
to make that whole thing crumble and it
seemed that they siphoned off the wealth
in my opinion Joe went from riches to
rags and he was helped all along the way
and other people rose up while Joe fell
down on the coral buskin now you've
mentioned your beliefs seem to align
with a lot of people's beliefs right now
how's she ever come off to you like have
you ever met this woman dee as she
because she was definitely mentioning
you and saying things about you come on
I am I am Carol's biggest nemesis Joe
stepped into the limelight because he
was fool enough take the bait and he was
running a shoddy setup it just wasn't
working out well for the animals you
know what he allowed himself make
terrible choices for how humane the
place was being run he never could find
good staff you know I have incredible
staff that have been here a lot of them
for decades and put it together and the
place look like [__]
wasn't going well Carol switch gears and
went after him because he went after her
he couldn't take the challenge Harold's
been attacking me as soon as she went
from hey I'm this cool cat and kid
selling you a tiger how to raise the
tiger wanna buy a tiger
she was the salesman that she's saying
everybody else is wrong for doing was
buying snow leopards and trying to
import cheetahs from Africa but
hell-bent on having the greatest
collection of big cats in the world but
she never came close to and that's we
absolutely have here it's amazing
collection and she went off the rails
and she after me with a
it's before Joe ever petted his first
little cub she was on me he's always
chased me down for that stuff but it's
never mattered cuz she's just a lying
cheating fool for those accusations and
everybody since I knew who she was said
everyday anytime Carol came up cuz every
cat person in America hates her guts
they said we all know she killed her
husband that's the mantra of the
industry long before Tiger King and I
talked with a woman who told me herself
her opinion but when Carol killed dawn
they held a gun to her head and they had
her sign the will with a gun to her head
she testified to it in court or in a in
a police report she testified to it and
it just never went anywhere have you
heard about the fact that the signatures
don't match up so Don's signatures on
everything else are consistent but on
that document that you've just met
mentioned there where he said that if I
disappear
it goes to Carol the signature is a
completely different signature it
doesn't even match up and yet and yet
they just processed this alright five
years he's dead
the kids get nothing I mean Carol is
ruthless you gotta give her that and
that [__] follows up behind you with a
can of sardines I'll you better start up
in here so you you believe she killed
her husband then I watch the show I've
heard the tales forever I believe she
did I believe the lady that I've known
for years that said a gun was held on
her she was forced to sign that document
as a witness I think that it's been that
way everyone knew and just kept
disappearing I think Tiger Kings only
good moment is that they put the
spotlight on this rancid [__] and that
people understand who she is and all you
really needed was good video of her
because she's crazy as a loon running
around talking crazy talk talking about
the enormous wealth she's if you
lady come from donations on her fax
forms which you can see on BCR watch.com
her tax forms clearly say she's making
more than four million dollars a year
ladies raked it in you take the money
that she's made plus that we're talking
tens of millions of dollars in income
everybody works for free the
veterinarian's are free
she's got free legal counsel going on
man this lady is crazy on BCR watch it
says that she owns over 90 homes in that
area she is a landlord extraordinaire
and what do you think happens if those
people don't pay their rent oh yeah
exactly
and we've had them in this country we've
had body language experts analyzing the
way she says I never threatened him and
you say in that moment where she says I
never threatened him her mouth does
something very strange at the end and we
they've really got her under the
spotlight like you're saying and it
seems to me like one of the things about
this woman is adulation she admits she
she groped without friends she had
imaginary cuts his friends she didn't
have normal relationships with people
and we all know people who kill people
that's how it always starts now I'm not
saying she did but it's it's an
indicator and then we've got the point
now way the spotlight is on her and it
just makes you wonder if she's craved
everyone to love her all those years and
now she's sending her husband out to do
this video on her behalf because she
can't even face the camera at the moment
for the scrutiny that to me it doesn't
speak of an innocence you know I agree
on a present she just looks like she's
falling off the edge the brand of Errol
Baskin Big Cat Rescue which is always
been just no.12 that whole brand has
taken a horrible hit and you're talking
about a brand that makes millions and
millions of dollars every year it's a
friend not just does it make that money
they throw lavish parties all the time
they have big expensive weddings they
get they have all these car dealerships
that sponsor them and people that just
are constantly giving her this big boost
and the other car
you maniacs that are out there Humane
Society PETA other big cat places
lunatics out there in Los Angeles Tippi
Hedren who runs another big cat rescue
system called Shambhala the other people
in Minnesota that run there's better her
buddies Thailand jumping on the
bandwagon they haven't asked to be on
your program I bet tell you why they
love Carol and understand her and those
cans of sardine oil have nothing to do
with the murder
no one's out there helping yeah I did
think when I watched her husband defend
her and he goes I've never had an
argument with her I thought you're not
helping things hear me you're really not
helping this I mean it 25 years you've
never argued I'm not buying it and if
you haven't there's some there's a
reason you're scared you know if you go
to a restaurant or you not love yeah you
know so what one of the things we know
it was your love life was brought up
obviously in this show and you know some
people seen he's got nine wives three
wives four wise five votes how was that
being because you've been under some
scrutiny yourself and what is the
situation what is the truth the truth is
25 years ago was the last time I was
married I was married to a lovely lady
who died in a car crash here in Myrtle
Beach
she's the father of me she's the mother
of Cody okay
my daughter tawny my youngest kids who
were 30 and 25 years old she's their mom
now that lady that's gone out of my life
I've been dating ever since you know
it's something that I do yes I'm running
around I have girls that I have spent
time with I've got more than one
girlfriend anytime and they know who
each other are they know I am the
character that I am and they're cool
with it why the hell is everybody else
got to have an opinion they're
pretending that they are young these are
girls that are 40 and 50 years old it's
our children it's all this idea B's all
these young girls only girls were shown
in the special half of my staff or male
and they're out there saying look at all
these girls that is my granddaughter
that is mine
that is my nephew's significant other
that's my son Cody's girlfriend that is
other characters that are married and
have a life partners here the young
girls are all those guys connection to
those women none of those have a
relationship with me I am the boss I am
there those girls are all intimately
connected to my family and then it is my
family my two big beautiful daughters
are the bright shining beauty queens
here at the facility people all the time
because they come up they hug me they
got my arm around me and now a tiger
kingdom I that must be one of those
girls like I am not married and I live
alone in my own house and I had visitors
on my guy I appreciate that and I
respect that what I wanted to ask if
this is okay I've known men in my life
who when they have lost the love of
their life they don't try and replace
that they go and say you know I had that
person and now I'm going to try and
enjoy life while it's here but no one
will ever be her and was there a bit of
that in your mind as you move forward
with your life certainly in the
beginning is this is 25 years ago in the
beginning I have this incredible girl
she helped me build and run and help my
whole facility operate and it was tragic
to lose her but the process throughout
my life is been victory
I have regrouped and moved on through
life good bad and ugly things I hope I
survive Tiger Kings it's all of those
yeah and and I am I love girls I chase
girls I love adult girls with a powerful
mindset my girls stand toe-to-toe with
adult lions and tigers and are happy to
say we're going this way let's go these
are powerful women who in their own
right make this entire facility operate
who spend an incredible amount of time
with wildlife and that takes a very
powerful mindset the simple reflection
that this
little girl Barbara Fisher oh I was
there with a part-time babysitter nanny
visited us hung around for a few months
babysat my daughter did a show with me
fell in love with a guy that Joe stood
Portman on horseback no like night Vale
got pregnant and moved away with that to
a year later she shows back up and says
yeah I didn't have the baby yeah I want
to come back but I just helped you watch
the kids again I said sure come on
I traveled off to Africa at incredible
adventures there I have since I was a
kid I had to go to Thailand and work on
a tiger conservation I went off to the
Bahamas doing all this work and I took
my significant other girlfriends with me
the same ones that are still here I took
them with me and they helped watch over
the stuff as well and then she came back
to the state to think one of the African
guys comes back and says with me and she
says I'll marry and give me a visa
he says she gets pregnant as well the
other girl Barbra's know me and they
start slugging each other it's pissin
like crazy
she's prego she runs off again I don't
see her for another year she calls me
says I want to be a chef help me be a
chef and I'll I'll come back and cook
for you well we always need a cook I
send her money I put her through chef
school she fails out of chef's for some
point some time comes back I'm marrying
this new dude I wouldn't come help you
for the summer and take pictures and
help with taking care of some Bobson
well I watch kids again
I said you P come on we need somebody to
watch it the kids love to grow it
herself
he comes he just stays a couple months
she doesn't fulfill her contract he runs
off again she calls me all the time
three years for ten more years oh I want
to come see you I want to come hang out
again I want to bring my kids that I've
kept now and I want to interact I'm
gonna do something we shined you're
saying no you're not welcome we don't
what do you want you you know you're
kind of a
psychopath you're really a psychopath no
you're a [__] psychopath and we don't
let her come back starts writing
assistant is this the girl in the
documentary who claims all of these
things okay this is Barbara Fisher and
the document drive should have been
clear in the beginning knuckle it's
there Harbor fissure runs through this
hole in sanity with me it all develops
up he runs through this gamut of coming
and going coming and going and she's
gone she writes the salacious stories
about me and stuff never gets any real
press then the tiger King people see
some of it and they think wow this is
the story will latch on to they
interview 16 women they talk to all of
them they ask every one of them
salacious [__] Oh have you been
sexually compromised is doc chasing you
they all say of course not nothing works
out a girl that they've got putting on
the makeup and being so pretty that's
what I'm that's my friend dr. Robert
Ronson to teach her here at the
university that girl helps us run our
shows and takes care of animals with us
that's his fiancee insinuating she's in
the harem she's living in the guard or
some crazy land just because they could
wire 16 chicks interviewed one made it
on their it paid 10,000 bucks for these
interviews now none of them said the
right thing they went all over the
country found all my old staff at 350 of
these kids works for me male and female
of course 50/50 probably and bad you say
there's not another soul in the dock you
you're totally right though this is a
manure it's my job that sort of
challenge you but now you're saying this
I just sparked them I'd like none of
your you know current staff were given
even a minute half a minute nothing none
of it was in there nothing and you'd
assume they would ask them a [__]
question
interviewed them for day both a solid
foot here yeah never be that's the
norm here unless they've got some
tragedy in their life or unless they
marry somebody outside the group we've
had some really great staff who've
gotten married and moved away you know
that that's just happened I had a kid
from Israel here who is just such a
strong character help somebody she beat
he married one of the girls he wasn't
hip to the note of being here he moves
away I lost a ton of guys because of
that but all the staff are interviewed
and there are half men here they
interviewed none of the men of course
they talked to all of them for hours as
well not even take a snapshot of them do
every girl is there a lot of them are
keep looking girls they do every girl
they take them from every angle if
they're clapping the hand they [__]
show them on Halloween dressed up in
weird clothes and they don't tell you
it's Halloween and that [__] is on
there talking saying hey he made us
dress and funny clothes
he made us act sexual they're up there
being like Halloween crazy they're
allowed to party and drink and goof
around
I'm a videotape that and don't tell you
that's what's happening that little
girl's got whiskers drawn on her lips I
think I'm making the chicks wear
whiskers in the day Halloween yeah so
yes at the audience It was as if it was
like you your son and just a whole order
women who apparently have been made or
forced to change their names well yes it
is this is this this name changing thing
it's not something you just do for four
nor is there any reason or is that not
even true what's the score I am the
master of all nicknames Nick these who
helped me set up this stuff his name is
patty whack and I've been calling patty
and patty whack all the time you know
it's just what I do I always use
nicknames and they and they stick over
time I also think that nicknames help
people to like be here quicker to not
mistake who else is being called god
forbid I have two guys named Rob at one
time I'm gonna stole one of them
else but Rob I have a beautiful big lion
named Arthur and Arthur was my client
guy attitude command card working good
guys damn name's Arthur I said [__] that
you cannot be Arthur her name is oh no
like why did she call you Thor he's got
some problem with Greek mythology I mean
Norse mythology I'm like calling the
Lions name that's why he's named Thor
he's kept it to this day yes Kumail
particular name but 1:1 so just a cover
of what this woman said just to give you
your fair shot so people know this of us
this she was saying boob jobs
cockroaches any of that yeah those jobs
and cockroaches in the United States if
you go to a board-certified surgeon and
you say hey I want some boobs
you gotta go in and have three in-depth
meetings this girl went to a guy that we
know well sewed up my nose when a
leopard knocked it off he sewed up
Cody's chin thought he went and got the
gigantic gauge earrings looks like you
the guy that might have those those big
earrings and those back down he's just a
guy he met Barbara Fisher she
interviewed with him as is necessary you
have to hold the boobs in your hands you
gotta measure them you gotta take
photographs you gotta have the photos to
do a comparison chart not simple they'll
get a good boob job in America it goes
through all that you can't pay for him
she has to finance them that girl from a
boob job payments for five years maybe
longer I don't even know she was
obsessed with having boobs those boobs
didn't live here she's living out there
that's driving them on every that's not
like something that was part of the game
that had to happen here cockroaches this
is a USDA licensed facility we have
unannounced inspections that happen here
three to four times a year by spent
Broll veterinarians this isn't a thing
to maintain your license for us smooth
sailing crappy place that's what puts
pressure on you either be good or get
out of the game these people come almost
all of them are women they come and
check everything they want a glove test
up so they're looking for every little
nuance if you have cockroaches you're
going down you can't have cockroaches
running around you gotta have surfaces
clean you gotta have refrigerators that
are spotless if you had a single bag a
loaf of bread it had a cockroach in it
they would write you up
you got written up twice it's 10,000
bucks for each occurrence like that if
you got write written up regularly he'll
take your license you look at those
other characters in the show that
outrageous guy hey Tim start it's saying
wild stuff he's also crazy about girls
and he's somehow connecting his
craziness with mine
it's absolutely opposite he's there he's
got his permit taken away from him oh
he's permanent taken away from him as
another big place called Dade City
that's been under the gun with Joe and
the big lawsuit that's happened here in
the States
his permits taking away her permit
that's low it's right now how they're
trying to take his permit away he will
lose that zoo mark my words that place
Jeff Lewis something's like an [__]
Oh such a little douche you know first
thing is man he's short
he's got a massive ego nothing but
trouble in his entire life he's a he's a
full-time con man so anyway back to
cockroaches you can't have bugs a single
Mouse will be written up if you have a
bowl that's turned upside down it's
clean its upright and a mouse ran
through it if you saw a footprint or a
turd in there right there man that's a
violation twice that's 10,000 bucks
can't do these things she's making
outrageous statements but of course
can't be true there's federal reports
that anyone can read to say that the
place is spotless and an amazing
facility all right I haven't got too
many more questions I do appreciate your
time is valuable buddy
did you see Donald Trump on the news
saying he is going to look and enjoy
exotic alright crazy land hey it's it's
phenomenal that anything makes it all
the way from Netflix who the president
Sears I think one of his kids has been
watching the show and got riled up about
it and probably didn't tell God but told
some reporter or something what do you
know Tiger King you know and I've heard
it um Kim Kardashian and her husband
there are trying to get Joe a pardon
from the president that also I saw a pop
up on a feed I don't know the truth of
it but it's kind of crazy land I can't
imagine that will happen I would i think
the joke would potentially get a new
trial to happen and he could get an
appeal i think that's probably a good
thing he would have an appeal come up so
that the fact could be presented more
clearly I think him having an attorney
that only was working for him on for
free you know that the appointed
attorney is really difficult it go
exotic had OJ Simpson's legal team Jodi
walking around today singing you know I
was so devastated when I realized he
didn't actually sing all those [__]
songs I'm not sure contract harmony or
backup I've heard Joe sing a little bit
he's not a bad singer you can just
barely carry a tune and they synthesized
you it can roll out I'm not sure those
are bums just jumping on the wagon Joe's
not the end he's not a bad singer and
there's some bad singers have had some
hit songs you know how can we ever
forget vanilla ice or me the one that
Carol Baskin had made that music video
she hadn't where him and her husband are
sitting on the couch and this husband
he's like just shoot me now like it was
terrible
I'd rather be dead than listen about yes
do you do you think you will see Joe
exotic as a free man if you had
put money on it where would you go bad
put money on it I think that it's 50/50
Joe could get out so I'd be a little
afraid to take the bet I might throw a
thousand at ten to one odds tokens gonna
get out I wouldn't go is straight up bet
on it okay it's too much [__] that's
happened and I think entrapment is there
and I think that he faced wildlife
charges but many other people have
committed the same crime and they always
look the other way if Polly Murr at the
zoo loses an arm because it gets cancer
and it's arm falls off and it's of
cancer the veterinarians don't wait for
the lemur to die suffering they
euthanize it their sake and Joe's trial
as I understand it but the euthanasia of
any tiger is a crime at any time so that
sounds to me like it's contrived to make
Joe look worse to the jury who didn't
know the insanity of the Caryl Baskin
drama and try to put him in a
predicament where they could make him
here to be a bad bad guy not that he
didn't do bad bad things but I don't
know be good twenty two years worth and
OJ's out so I don't know how this all
works really I do feel like I feel like
the guy because he was flapping his gums
and telling everyone how he's gonna do
this to Carol and that the Carol if
anything that makes me more inclined to
think he would never have done it it was
just all [__] and he was just trying
to intimidate her but on the coral do
you think she could potentially they
could switch roles maybe or even do you
think anything will come of this with
Carol do you think she could end up in a
cage I think it's possible
pull up circumstantial evidence it makes
her being looked at but I don't know
without a body if it's possible in the
u.s. no body and murder charges very
hard to connect together you'd have to
have the hit man that helped her testify
saying I was paying here's the proof now
his wife suppose
and come forward that's also on PCR Oh
calm his wife came forward and put a
letter out that said I'm the hit man's
wife this is when he did it this is how
much she paid him she allude to that
same thing because he was paid in guns
and with a van and she said unsolicited
this dude dango he had a but not all of
dogs guns and guns and fawn disappeared
in Costa Rica and the whole thing looks
really messy maybe something like that
could happen but I can't see how that
hit man's actually out of prison I've
been told he doesn't want to go back so
why would he indicate himself unless
they gave him a deal like Jeff flow and
said hey you put care oh yeah you can do
it
that would be Tiger king - that would be
watching football that is that's the
script right there you've written it
here one three questions left they're
talking about making this into a movie
I was just wondering who you would have
play you if there's anyone who stands
out if they're gonna make Tiger King the
ridiculous sensationalized lyin cheatin
comedy into a movie and I gotta be
played by Will Ferrell yes he looks a
little bit like me you know yeah comedy
rolling because how can Tiger King be
anything but a comedy this is an
outrageous stuff it's not about the
truth there's no such thing as five
thousand Tigers lost in America it's all
a lie I think all of that's coming
closer and closer to coming out you know
I I think you could have the flamboyant
Joe and psychotic Carroll balancing back
and forth but I'm not sure it's a movie
I'm not sure that it you know you can in
90 minutes you can tell a good enough
tailback you know the right script you
can talk about a frickin manufacturer of
tires and make it interesting so I'll
see where it goes there's there's a lot
of people who seem to think that your
job is glamorous and ease
in phone but I was just wondering and
not necessarily in the way that some
people might think but is there any
parts of your job because you're working
with animals and you know naturally we
love animals that you feel like really
difficult and no one would know about or
maybe you feel a little bit of guilt
like oh like I can't believe have to do
that a day or is there anything there
that people wouldn't know about this is
running an agricultural operation right
this is a job that starts as the Sun
comes up or it in the right time of year
well before the Sun comes up this is a
job that happens way after the sunset it
never ends
seven days will be 18 hours a day there
are wildlife in your care that you must
be watching over but out at very
specific relationship you're not doing
to them the proper service which you
really need to run a quality
establishment nine to five animal care
is BS it will not work this job is so
long and so audience it's why so many
people don't actually stick if they
start think I'm gonna take care of
animals and they go oh my god my entire
life I don't go out I don't go places I
only go a conservation missions if I'm
vacationing that's the only thing I try
to go in and work on and do is go off to
Africa go off to Indonesia and check on
that kind of work it is my whole life
and that people don't understand I know
people think well it's okay it's with
animals they don't understand how
intense that is and there's also an
endless piece of stress I have these
incredible kids that are eternally two
years old they're there and they don't
quite get how to behave except these
guys have machine guns and if they get
out they can kill somebody and tear some
stuff up you've got this massive
responsibility round-the-clock to keep
an eyeball on them to make sure it's
there also people say oh it's so easy
all you do is hang out with animals I
have a diet chimpanzee
as big as me it's with me every night
for dinner I love he's cool but he's
there my son Cody's got another giant
chimpanzee sitting next to him at dinner
every night
those boys are gonna knock back five
thousand calories then they're gonna
peel some oranges and fling the peel you
know and they're gonna be wild and crazy
boys
it's an enormous commitment the what we
do it be understood unless you've lived
you mentioned guns there I just
remembered you sleep with an ak-47
apparently according to this show why do
you sleep with that gun I am the
in-charge I'm in charge of this
incredible facility here that has 80 big
cats they're going along I have all
those huge primates going along if
something tragic starts to take place a
weapon is a needed piece of the work
that we do I my life is threatened every
day one 250 times people say they want
to kill me gonna kill me gonna get me
because a pair of baskin malicious
insanity that she's written all of the
stuff she said I'm this evil dude people
think that there's something there I
don't know where the next crazy person
is gonna go I'm a professional cowboy I
grew up with a six-gun on my head when I
was 10 years old
but in my dad that's how we live and
that's what I've done that's the Wild
West that I grew up in so I always have
I in some automatic weapons found it I
also have variety of another 50 guns in
my life I have a pistol in my pocket I
have one in my glove box
I travel like that all the time we have
concealed weapons permits and we carry
guns when we're doing things as a
possibility of last result I've never
had to shoot an animal I don't ever
think I will have to shoot an animal but
there I have shot many different times
in the air one Tigers attack
another Tiger and they won't separate
and it I've come next to them and fired
at the air before fired in the dirt next
to my feet to create the shock and awe
skip them to stop trying to kill each
other it's very rare in a 40 year career
it's happened three times maybe in my
40-year career I'll be not in the last
decade but I'm not gonna be unprepared
better to have a gun and never need it
to need a gun and never had that never a
truer word spoken this last question I
like our sister all our guests how would
you like to be remembered there's one
more crazy thing at the end they roll up
the screen at Tiger King and they say
doc enters facility was just raided
complete [__] he's swearing okay on
your show all you can say whatever the
[__] you like my friend at the end the
show up rolls that screen it says stock
analyst facility was rated that's total
[__] it never happened there was a
team of veterinarians that came with the
state's attorney's office in Virginia
for a zoo that had been closed down in
Virginia I don't know the details of it
it seems a little fishy how they closed
it it was closed down by animal
activists and by animal rights people
and the state's attorneys some out they
wanted to find out where three lions
went the guy no longer claim to have now
this guy did a federal exchange with me
he had reliance he called me said I
cannot take care of him I'd be happy for
you to have him I know you'll provide
him a great home my daughter got in a
car drives up picked up those three
lions and put them back to our home in
here ever since
those Lions were registered on our
federal paperwork those Lions had a
statewide travel permit those lions are
registered and inspected already twice
by the US department of agricultural
federal veterinarians it's all in the
open they came and said no no we have to
test the DNA because you might say
they're not yours and you might say it's
different lines I said he's a federal
take a picture no no so we did these DNA
tests they asked for more documents they
wanted us anything else we had let us be
gave him access to every place there was
a file to say there's nothing here
it got on their merry way and went back
to Virginia I will probably never hear
from them again
I was in no way seem to have any
wrongdoing
I did nothing we were sure as hell never
raided if you are rated in America and
they're going out for criminal charges
it's all over the Internet the moment it
goes out it's a public piece of
understanding you're arrested if you're
being kind of be part of a crime even if
you're bailed out or whatever it's
public record there's none of that
because it's absolutely not true no I
mean I appreciate that and I'm glad you
cleared that up because you know a lot
of people kind of would have been left
with an impression of you after that
which isn't fair so how would you like
the girl you remembered if I was looking
to be remembered in one way it would be
that we made a substantial contribution
to saving the tiger the Tiger stance is
the last great Sentinel of the forest I
believe if we lose him we'll lose a
piece of ourselves forever I think by
saving the tiger we can save the world I
think the world is under enormous
pressure and this incredible character
of the tiger helps us to all feel better
that he's out there in the wild and then
he's there taking care as this overlord
for all things
mystical wild and fabulous I hope to
save him Oh future generations always
have Tiger can see him and I hope I can
be remembered from that one thing that
would be my proudest moment doc I know
it has been a pleasure I'm a thunder you
for coming on and I hope I hope we can
do this again sometime buddy and really
nothing would be as impactful as if you
came and visited me here come here I've
got this incredible place on the
waterfront down you're a beautiful big
place for celebrities and people to stay
at I'm gonna do some broadcasts from
there let me have a giant chip in your
lap baby tigers swim in a pool do that
stuff you would understand
animals in a way that you could not
imagine if you got to spend time with us
and it'd be a blast to do so roll on
over and see us it's a simple flight
I've done it a ton you can just make it
to Myrtle Beach and immerse yourself in
lions and tigers and bears hug an
elephant it's a baby cub it'll never
leave you
I've got to tuck in with a lion on my
arm actually so maybe I could get a
picture with it out you know next to an
actual lion that'll be good
so thanks again and obviously it will
put all your socials in the description
so people are going to check out
everything you're doing ok thanks guys
hope you've enjoyed the podcast and
we'll see you later